[Music]
welcome back it is time for in a minute
and we're teaming up with Banana
Republic to share some Staples that we
could all add to our Workwear or our
everyday wardrobe and here with the
fashion 411 is stylist Erica work hi
for having me so you know Debbie wanted
some new Workwear pieces that would not
just be from nine to five but that would
take her Beyond nine to five I'm talking
date night drinks with Friends Weekend
hangs you name it and thankfully Banana
Republic has created this beautiful
collection of versatile and elevated
pieces with glamorous luxurious Fabrics
built with comfort and style in mind I
have to say last night I wore this great
brown blouse with a pair of boots and
this beige suede skirt it's my new
favorite piece of clothing I think
banana is rocking it right now you're
talking about it's also in my checkout
list that's how much I love it no I know
I think the whole look right now really
does transcend from day to night and I
mean take me through this look I wanted
to start Debbie off with a fabulous
topper and I feel like the trench is
such a Timeless staple it's really easy
to dress up or down depending what you
Style with it and a hot tip I don't know
about you drew but I love a ruched
sleeve moment but I find like over time
they slide down so a stylist hack that I
swear by you take hair elastics you put
one on each arm and then you rush it up
to the desired sleeve length and there's
a little peekaboo moment here the hair
elastic is right here it holds its space
you take the excess fabric over top and
she looks incredibly Chic yeah
what are the pants okay the other thing
I wanted Debbie to have in her wardrobe
is a fabulous pair of high-rise wide leg
trousers and I'm obsessed with these
this is a universally flattering
silhouette that works on everyone she
can wear this with a heel or she can
dress it down with a pair of kicks but
what I'll say is if you're going to take
it to the tailor another stylist hot tip
right so you're actually going to want
to tell them to keep it a little bit
longer in the front and a little bit
shorter in the back so that that way
when you're walking around your pants
don't drag and the last way longer in
your wardrobe it also gives you a longer
leg yes but without tripping on it
jewelry I love the whole look you are
you are so beautiful thank you
so we had so much fun yeah well I cannot
thank you enough Erica and I live for
these types of tips and tricks and
that's ultimately what fashion is all
about it's meant to build your
confidence and feel great it's meant to
be fun it's playful it's like Debbie
well guess what I'm actually wearing
Banana Republic too
I'm gonna run back to Banana Republic
and buy more clothes and everybody we
make this show for you so just wherever
you are in this world take it with you
because it was made for you
[Music]